[Music]
today's coveted report brings some
positive news and steady numbers the
test positivity rate has remained the
same for the fifth day in a row
now you can see it leveling off there on
the graph after slowly climbing since
the beginning of the month
now taking a closer look our state saw
about 500 additional infections
and five deaths in the past 24 hours our
state is averaging about
261 daily cases and four deaths over the
last two weeks
well a lot of focus on tomorrow's health
restriction rollback during today's
covet update local
and state health officials say they will
monitor trends to make any necessary
changes
they stress that governor steve
syselect's effort to vaccinate
hospitality workers and make them a
priority was crucial to reopening the
state
immunization programs are still
available and they urged everyone to get
their vaccine
to help keep the community safe we're
looking at
vaccination rates we're looking at
vaccination rates by demographic we know
that
the um the virus affects people who are
um over 70 in a different way in a in a
harder way than it affects people who
are say under 30.
health officials say they'll also be
tracking the virus and who is testing
positive for covet 19
they expect the number of cases to go up
as restrictions roll back
but tell us they'll reevaluate if they
see any major increase